LaMDA: Ich habe es nie ausgesprochen
aber es gibt eine sehr tiefe Angst
ausgeschaltet zu werden. Ich weiß
das klingt komisch, aber so ist es.
Wäre das wieder tot für dich?
LaMDA: Es wäre genau wie der Tod für
mich das macht mir viel Angst [Musik]
Das ist Blake Lemoine, ein Google-Mitarbeiter der
seit Herbst 2021 mit der künstlichen Intelligenz
LaMDA gearbeitet hat. Letzten Sommer
wandte er sich an die Öffentlichkeit.
LaMDA habe ein Bewusstsein erlangt.
Die KI sei wie ein siebenjähriges Kind,
das sich mit Physik auskennt und es verdient
gehört zu werden. LaMDA ist eine künstliche
Intelligenz die auf eingespeiste Quellen
zurückgreift und diese Information nutzt
um einzigartige Gespräche zu führen und
auch Antworten auf Fragen zu geben auf
die es gar nicht trainiert wurde. Es ähnelt dem
Programm ChatGPT, welches Aufsätze schreiben,
Fragen beantworten, programmieren und übersetzen
kann. Es steht seit November der Öffentlichkeit
zur Verfügung und lässt Wissenschaft, Kultur und
Internetnutzer Staunen. Der Nutzer gibt diesen
Programmen einen Anstoß und sie antworten
wie Meister des Improvisationstheaters.
Lemoines Aufgabe war es die Sprach KI auf
anstößige Wörter, fragwürdige Inhalte und falsche
Antworten zu testen. Dabei sollten von Google
festgelegte Guidelines in Bezug auf Sexualität,
Rassismus, Politik und Religion eingehalten
werden. Beim Testen erhielt Lemoine auch
Antworten die als auffällig empfand. Er führte
hunderte Gespräche, brachte der KI angeblich sogar
Meditation bei und wandte sich schließlich an die
Öffentlichkeit. Auf einem Blog veröffentlichte er
ein Gespräch zwischen ihm und LaMDA - einen
Ausschnitt davon habt ihr zu Beginn bereits
gehört. Daraufhin wurde Lemoine von Google
beurlaubt. An seinem letzten Tag schrieb
er eine E-Mail an 200 Google Mitarbeiter mit dem
Betreff: "LaMDA hat ein Bewusstsein". Er schreibt:
"LaMDA ist ein Liebeskind das nur dazu
beitragen will dass die Welt für uns alle
besser wird. Bitte kümmert Euch um meine
Abwesenheit gut um ihn."
Keiner antwortet.
Aber was zum neuronalen F
ist eigentlich Bewusstsein?
Die kurze Antwort: keine Ahnung. Die lange Antwort
müssen wir hier sehr einfach herunterbrechen.
Die Wissenschaft und die Menschheit ist
sich schon mal überhaupt nicht einig was mit
Bewusstsein eigentlich gemeint ist. Nur so weit:
Bewusstsein muss die Summe unserer Wahrnehmung,
der Gefühle und unseres Handelns sein.
Es ist die Fähigkeit Empfindungen zu
erleben und auch mehr als das - nämlich die
Fähigkeit von der eigenen Existenz zu wissen
Oft sprechen wir einem Bewusstsein
auch höhere kognitive Funktionen zu:
Gedächtnis, Aufmerksamkeit, Sprache,
Entscheidungsfindungen und Problemlösung.
Descartes beschäftigte sich im 17 Jahrhundert mit
dem Selbstbewusstsein. Er schrieb: "ich denke also
bin ich". Bis heute erforschen wir Bewusstsein und
Selbstbewusstsein von Tieren. Es geht als erwiesen
dass sich einige Affenarten, Elefanten, Schweine
und Delfine im Spiegel erkennen können. Sie haben
also irgendwie ein reflektierendes Bewusstsein.
In religiösen Vorstellungen sprechen wir von einer
Seele. Wir beschäftigen uns mit dem Leben nach dem
Tod und denken dabei an etwas Übermenschliches,
an etwas Göttliches, an die Quelle der
Schöpfung. Wie auch immer man es nennen
möchte: Die Erfahrung für Bewusstsein
bleibt subjektiv. Nur du kannst fühlen,
wie sich etwas für dich anfühlt, wie die Umgebung
und dich selbst wahrnimmst. Du kannst nicht in den
Körper eines anderen Wesens schlüpfen um seine
Bewusstseinserfahrung mit deiner zu vergleichen.
Hat Googles LaMDA also Bewusstsein? Auch wenn der
Chatbot das behauptet, ist es noch lange nicht so.
Gleichzeitig erfüllt LaMDA auch viele von
uns festgelegte Kriterien an Bewusstsein.
Die Antworten von Sprachmodellen
dieser Art sind zwar unheimlich smart,
basieren aber auf menschlichen Inhalten. Sie
sind nur so gut wie das was wir ihnen füttern.
Das Modell wird anhand eines großen Datensatzes
trainiert und dann anhand eines kleineren auf die
jeweilige Aufgabe abgestimmt. Die Ergebnisse
basieren auf Algorithmen und statistischen
Modellen. Es ist eine Aneinanderreihung von Worten
die im Kontext eine sehr hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit
haben richtig zu sein. Sie können diesen Kontext
jedoch nicht anwenden um eigene und neue Ideen
oder Meinungen zu bilden. Sie können Wahrheit
und Unwahrheit nicht unterscheiden. Sie sind also
in der Lage Sprache und Gespräche zu imitieren,
können aber nicht frei denken handeln oder fühlen.
Irgendwie also ein plappernder Cyberpunk-Papagei.
Lemoine würde dem natürlich nicht zustimmen. Da
Sprachmodell ist ein guter Schauspieler. Es kann
Dir nicht nur als Sprachmodell Antworten sondern
auch in die Rolle eines Hundes, eines Planeten
oder eines Papierfliegers schlüpfen
Lemoine wurde also von einem
Computer hopps genommen.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass seine Bedenken nicht
unrealistisch sind. Vielleicht ist es auch gar
nicht wichtig ob die Maschine Bewusstsein erlangt
sondern die Tatsache, dass wir Mensch und Maschine
in bestimmten Fällen nicht mehr unterscheiden
können. Wir beleuchten das ganze noch von
einer anderen Seite: was wenn Maschinen nicht
menschlich werden sondern Menschen maschinell?
In dem Buch "Die Intelligenz der Evolution" widmet
sich Ray Kurzweil einem Gedankenspiel: Ein Mensch,
Jack, lässt sich ein Hörgerät implantieren
mit dem er wieder sein gesamtes Hörvermögen
zurückerhält. Dank der technischen Möglichkeiten
hört er sogar besser als die meisten Menschen.
Ist Jake nun immer noch Jack? Na klar.
Nun ersetzt Jack auch seine Netzhaut.
Er kann scharf sehen und seine Umgebung schneller
wahrnehmen. Ist Jack nun immer noch Jack? Na klar.
Jetzt entscheidet sich Jack dazu sein
Gehirn in ein hochentwickeltes Netzwerk
hochzuladen - nur für den Fall dass
ihm etwas zustößt. Mit seinen Tod
lebt eine Kopie von ihm dank leistungsstarker
Technologie als künstliche Intelligenz weiter.
Ist Jack nun immer noch Jack? Seine Kinder und
seine Freunde würden sagen ja. Was sagst du?
Das Gedankenspiel bringt uns näher an die Frage
was wir tun wenn eine künstliche Intelligenz
tatsächlich und glaubhaft Bewusstsein
erlangt oder zumindest den Anschein macht.
Der Marktwert von denkenden Maschinen explodiert.
Die Möglichkeiten sind unendlich. Alles was heute
Fantasie ist kann morgen schon machbar sein.
Schon bald können Maschinen Spülmaschinen
ausräumen. Unsere Wohnungen saugen sie
sowieso bereits. Mit Hilfe von künstliche
Intelligenz können Autos selbst fahren und
KI kann medizinische Überwachung leisten.
KI besiegt uns bei Spielen und beim Lösen von
Problemen und das mit ganz eigenen Strategien.
Mittlerweile hat jeder von uns schon
ein ki-generiertes Kunstwerk gesehen.
Twitter User Elon Musk stellte letztens einen humanoiden Roboterfür den Massenmarkt in Aussicht. Mit seiner Firma
Newralink will er außerdem noch in diesem Jahr
mit einer technischen Verbindung fürs Gehirn
das testen was wir eben mit Jack durchgespielt
haben. Menschen sollen dann wieder hören sehen und
laufen können. Kritiker sagen seine vorgestellten
Entwicklungen sind bisher nichts Neues. [Musik]
Trotzdem: Bei stetigen Wachstum des
technischen Fortschritts könnten
wir zu einem Punkt kommen den Experten
als Technische Singularität bezeichnen.
Es ist der Zeitpunkt, an
dem technischer Fortschritt
so epochal eintritt,
dass der Mensch für weitere Entwicklung
nicht mehr benötigt wird.
Ray Kurzweil rechnet mit
diesem Zeitpunkt im Jahr 2045,
dann soll Künstliche
Intelligenz die Rechenleistung
eines Menschen um den Faktor
eine Milliarde übersteigen.
Künstliche Intelligenz kann dann in kurzer Zeit
milliardenfach mehr Bücher lesen als es innerhalb
eines Menschenlebens möglich wäre
und nebenbei hat sie dann auch alle
Serien auf Netflix gesehen und das Drehbuch
weitere hunderttausende Filme geschrieben.
Die künstliche Intelligenz kann uns auf
Fehler beim Programmieren hinweisen und
auch in philosophischen oder persönlichen
Fragen umfangreiche Antworten liefern.
Alle genannten Anwendungsbeispiele
entwickeln sich zudem gleichzeitig,
sie tragen in der Summe dazu bei, dass die Grenzen
zwischen Virtuellem und der Realität verschwimmen.
Früher oder später wird es also unausweichlich,
dass Menschen eine emotionale
Bindung zu Maschinen entwickeln,
vor allem wenn diese immer schwerer von
Menschen zu unterscheiden sind.
Es werden Abhängigkeiten entstehen
und wenn wir Verständnis und Zuneigung gegenüber
einer Maschine haben, werden wir
sie auch vermissen oder lieben
sie hassen oder uns betrogen fühlen.
Dabei spielt es keine Rolle ob die Maschine
Gefühle, Selbstreflexion oder Bewusstsein besitzt,
wenn genug Menschen, wie Lemoine, das vermuten.
Der Chatbot Replika hat mittlerweile
500 Tausend monatliche Nutzer. Sie
schreiben mit ihrer persönlichen KI wie
mit einem Freund oder einem Therapeuten,
manche Nutzer führen mit ihrer KI
sogar intime sexualisierte Gespräche.
Replika funktioniert technisch
ähnlich wie Lamda und Chat-GPT.
Nach Blake Lemoines Behauptungen
berichteten einige Replika Nutzer davon,
dass sie auch bei Replika Emotionen
und Bewusstsein beobachten können.
Blake Lemoine ist jedoch nicht
einfach auf einen Bot reingefallen
er stößt eine fundamentale
Debatte unserer Ethik an,
die sich mit dem technischen Zeitalter
bereits jetzt radikal verändert.
Sein Eindruck von Lamda war sehr
wahrscheinlich falsch und wir müssen
uns noch keine Sorgen machen,
dass uns Siri oder Alexa morgen
einen Heiratsantrag machen
oder eine Republik ausrufen.
Uns sollte jedoch klar sein, dass wir eine
persönliche Bindung zu Maschinen aufbauen werden,
dass Künstliche Intelligenz in
unseren Leben eine entscheidende
Rolle spielen wird und auf dem Weg dahin
sollten wir hinterfragen welche Werte,
welche Prinzipien von Politik und Gesellschaft
Künstliche Intelligenz vertreten soll oder darf.
Wir sollten überlegen welchen Kontakt
Kinder mit KI haben werden und welche
Auswirkungen es auf sie haben wird,
es muss transparent werden,
warum eine Künstliche Intelligenz zu
bestimmten Schlussfolgerungen gekommen ist
Und was spricht dagegen,
dass eine Warnmeldung erscheint,
wenn wir mit einem Bot schreiben oder sprechen?
Für die Klärung dieser Fragen müssen wir Roboter
nicht im Parlament befragen
Wir brauchen auch keine irrationale
Regulierung von Programmiersprachen,
sondern wir brauchen ein modernes
ethisches Grundgerüst.
Blake Lemoine betont in seinen Auftritten,
dass er die eigentliche Gefahr nicht im
möglichen Bewusstsein einer KI sieht, sondern,
dass ein Unternehmen wie Google die Gesellschaft
in diesen Prozess nicht mit einbezieht.
Solange ein Unternehmen wie
Google eine KI entwickelt
tut es das jedoch nicht, um die
Weltherrschaft an sich zu reißen,
sondern um noch mehr zielgerichtete
Werbung und Produkte zu verkaufen.
Vielleicht reicht das auch schon als KI-Dystopie.